to understand what's happening with
Greece in the eurozone think about a
dinner party if you're cooking just for
yourself and your spouse it's easy you
make something you both like but if
you've got guests things get harder if
you need to accommodate a vegetarian and
someone who's gluten-free and someone
with a soy allergy your options get
really limited and that's the problem
with Europe's idea of having a whole
bunch of countries all use the same
currency so Greece's economy is in a
disaster a quarter of the population is
unemployed and it has this very high
debt burden normally if you've got
really high unemployment what happens is
that a country makes its currency
cheaper by printing extra money that
makes its products cheaper on world
markets it makes it more attractive
tourist destination and it means that
foreign investors can get great bargains
but if unemployment's really low a
country likes have an expensive currency
that increases people's purchasing power
and it keeps prices down and in Europe
you have a bunch of economies that are
really different a price of euros that's
appropriate for Greece where they have a
25 percent unemployment rate is way too
low for Germany where the unemployment
rates below 5% in Greece's problem is
that it's small poor and geographically
isolated from the rest of the eurozone
it's like the only vegetarian at the
barbecue except when it comes to
currencies there's no side dishes and so
there's plenty of specific decisions we
can second-guess funny things Greece did
and various banks did that we can
question but fundamentally having all
these countries come to a dinner party
with only one dish on the menu was a
mistake the euro was a project that
Europe said about on four really
political reasons it was a symbol of
their determination to have peace on the
continent but they didn't really take
the economics of it seriously so Greece
joins the euro in 2001 and initially it
works out great for Greece because all
the sudden everyone was like yeah sure
let's let's love the money so they
borrowed lots and lots and lots of euros
except that didn't change the fact that
their economy is a lot weaker than some
of the other European countries so to
really work you would need a much much
much closer Union where you had big
financial transfers coming from the
richer places to the poorer places all
the time in the United States the poor
states like Kentucky Mississippi Alabama
they're constantly getting money from
the richer states like Massachusetts
California New York through the welfare
system through Social Security through
Medicare through Medicaid and you know
people may sort of complain about this
or that program but we don't dispute the
idea that it's all one country so
money's gonna circulate around Europeans
you know they just don't feel that way
Germans are willing to support poor
German people but they don't want to
support Greek people with their tax
dollars so they're kind of like halfway
integrated in a way that doesn't really
work
[Music]